the following trailer is rated as for
spoilers
[Music]
in a world where ipe can rip for long
Wes Craven's signature franchise will go
on without him for a scarily honest look
at the state of the slasher genre they
are really out of ideas by now I've seen
this movie before you might actually be
them five at screen 22 or uh just scream
again that works I guess ghost face is
back in Woodsboro because where else can
you kill people in broad daylight and
get away with it
watch is a high schooler's attack kicks
off a high school reunion for that film
you watched in high school and ends up
being the best scream since the first
one because it basically is the first
one slightly updated for a modern
audience
one sec
hello hello Mr plinkett uh wrong number
it's the Honest Trailer guy hmm I guess
you'll have to do do you like meta
movies I mean sure if they're done well
what about metamovie promotional tie-ins
yeah not interested all your favorite
characters are back but they only had
the budget to de-age one of them there's
ex-cob Dewey who's a broken man after a
lifetime of carrying this town sorry ass
police force on his back
watching my sister
the tag team of Sydney and Gail two
queens who are so used to this gaping
stomach wounds are no big deal anymore
thank you both for everything and of
course the iconic horror villain ghost
face
oh man I thought I put that on silent do
you mind I'm trying to record here hang
up on me again and I'll cut you like an
elk don't you mean like a fish fish
would have been too predictable it's
called subverting expectations all right
look it I'm a little bit busy right now
too busy to mention how Scream is
available to watch now on Apple TV and
other digital retailers of course it's
available that movie came out in 96. not
oh scream new scream Oh you mean five
cream
at what passes for a joke around here we
usually save all the dumb puns for the
end still
I Cinema sends had the decency to call
it
quit yeah they're still going on too
what come on look you've had five movies
and three seasons to deconstruct a genre
that wasn't even complex to begin with
okay so don't let your ass about hanging
around too long Sydney please do the
honors I'm bored
watch these somehow still living legends
hand the franchise off to gen Z which is
cruel since their greatest fears having
to actually talk on the phone
foreign
that understands the only thing scarier
than one film door chasing you with a
knife is five film dorks subjecting you
to their movie opinions no connection
with the other movies no Legacy
characters at all if you ask me this
whole franchise goes off the rails
original is their favorite thing in the
world and God help anyone who's slightly
because nobody takes the true fans
seriously they just laugh at us and why
you know it's like a camera but with
complex emotional and thematic
underpinnings it's not just some slacky
cheese oh make it stop like this guy Wes
who's super knowledgeable about horror
movie cliches oh I see what you did
there Tara who tells you she doesn't
watch horror without telling you she
doesn't watch horror what's your
favorite scary movie uh The babadook
Mindy is basically the new Randy as a
recall which is not quite a reboot not
quite a sequel her twin Chad who is well
also the new Randy I'm not like entirely
sure that you're not the killer actually
most of these new characters are ready
pepper spray check taser check
girlfriend or Pilot check
you know that pardon horror movies where
you want to yell at the characters to be
smart and get the [ __ ] out this is that
part Richie
Liv she's there you said I was too
boring to be the killer new heroine Sam
who inherited her dad's Killer Instinct
but not his spatial awareness
you're in Stu mocker's house where your
dad and still killed everyone and I
didn't even realize that Dad was
standing right behind me and Amber and
Richie one is the main character's
boyfriend the other is a kook who lives
in Stu's house so you do the math oh my
gosh these things are so predictable who
put a landline in here
hello like I don't know who it is I told
you not to hang up trailer boy now I'm
gonna have to kill you okay look Mr and
or Miss face you're a legend and all but
with all due respect you've been getting
your ass kicked by teenagers since the
90s okay not exactly shaking him a robe
lucky shot
wow the floor was wet
I had sweat in my eye holes
okay that one was pretty embarrassing
you know most of these aren't even me
right I'm a different person in every
film we just all use the same spooky
voice modulator okay what you do is a
fight to an invalid in this one twice
I'm not one of those brute strength
slashers anyway I'm more into clever
misdirection let me guess you're gonna
lure me out of this booth by putting my
friends in danger then pop out and stab
me haha joke's on you I don't have any
friends well that's depressing yeah
you're telling me I just sit at home and
get worked up over these big movies
hoping they'll be good enough to make me
forget how alone I feel but they always
fall short and everybody else seems to
love them for some reason so fine go
ahead cut me open already hey I get
where you're coming from the whole
murder thing is just my way of inspiring
better content out of Hollywood you know
yeah I do We're Not So Different you and
I you're cute with knives and I kill
with the semi occasional decent joke
should we team up for the outro bro hell
yeah brother third act twist so now that
every big sequel or reboot is a
self-referential circle jerk of fan
service return to the original franchise
to do just that because I love screen
you love scream we all scream for fried
crane we just become best friends uh yep
yep
story
never better the morning show do we or
do not there is no Troy he's just a
skeeter boy the starting girl in the
Frights the boy's friends the girl who
repeatedly Played with Fire the Jamie
Kennedy descendant and how come nobody
wants to talk about my actual favorite
genre young adult book adaptations
there's more than one way to kill a
teenager you know Ghost Face Jam a new
Legacy available now on digital April
5th on Blu-ray
you know who really sucks Sam and Tara's
mom both your daughters get attacked
multiple times and you can't come home
from a work conference yeah who's the
real monster here yes do you
you know I'm something of an epic voice
guy myself how do you like them apples
we've been trying to reach you about
your car's extended warranty
thanks for the nightmares